For decades,
people have dreamed
of technology that could
transport them somewhere else--
a teleporter machine
that would beam them
from point A to point B
just like that.
But will this technology
ever actually exist?
And if so,
what would it look like?
I'm Marques Brownlee,
and I review dope new tech.
But on this show,
I'm rewinding the clock
to look at the tech
of the past
that we thought
would be our future.
This is "Retro Tech:
Teleportation."
Hey, what's up?
MKBHD here.
So, I'm about
to unbox something.
Don't know what it is.
There's clearly
not a teleporter
under this desk, right?
Let's figure it out. Okay.
Wow, that is a colorful box.
Virtual Boy.
This is a console.
Interesting.
Virtual Boy, teleporters--
oh, is this
a virtual reality headset?
This graphic is
so incredibly '90s,
it's hard to tell
what's going on,
but I feel like
I'm seeing a VR headset.
And I guess if you're putting
two and two together,
teleportation really is, uh,
it's putting you
in a different place.
But in 1995,
with a good enough VR headset,
maybe that's the equivalent
of putting you
in a different place.
All right,
let's check this out.
Classic '90s packaging here.
Look at all those warnings.
"Carefully read
this whole thing."
"Don't put it on your face
if you're less than seven."
"May cause serious permanent
damage to their vision."
"May cause epilepsy
or seizures."
"Repetitive strain injury."
"Before playing,
consult a doctor."
Wow. Yeah, that's a lot.
That's a lot.
But, hey, it's red and black.
Not bad, Nintendo.
The tennis game,
I'm looking forward to that.
Batteries go in here.
Close it,
snap it onto the back.
Oh, man, I'd gone so long
without messing something up.
I remember exactly
how I took it off,
and it doesn't go back on
the same way.
I'm blowing my own mind
right now.
It should just slide down
these rails.
Okay, we got this.
There you go.
Looks like a four-inch display.
All red, dot matrix.
Mario versus Princess.
Okay, I've got my backhand.
Hit. I hit the ball
back at 'em.
The ball's coming back at me.
Oh, I missed,
and I am now losing.
Wow, I'm-- I'm impressed.
Now, I definitely
don't feel like
this is teleporting yet,
but if today's
virtual reality is, like,
the closest thing
we have to teleportation,
then this is
the early version of that.
But that's
what we're here out,
so let's get into it.
First thing
I'm gonna ask you to do
is check underneath
your chair.
Ooh, Oprah moment.
All right.
I don't know
what I'm holding right now.
- I find it fascinating.
- Uh, these would be--
( plays "Star Trek"
teleporter sound )
Oh, it-- it works!
I am holding
a miniaturized teleporter.
- That's fantastic.
- Beam me up.
Marques:
So, I guess, let's break down
in its simplest terms,
what exactly is teleportation?
What is this concept?
There's that famous expression,
the quickest way
from point A to point B
is a straight line.
And the idea of
teleportation is no line.
Sherri:
You're being beamed
at one location,
being beamed to another.
Like, instantaneous.
Speed of light.
It's some sort of a device
that you step into or step on,
and then you arrive
somewhere else,
on usually a matching device,
where you rematerialize
on that side.
There are so many movies
that have been built
around the theory
of teleportation.
Keith:
You have "Power Rangers."
They're teleporting.
But probably
the most iconic representation
of teleportation--
the transporter
in "Star Trek."
Mr. Spock, prepare
to beam Scotty on board.
"Star Trek" drilled home
that this could be future tech.
It's something that we wanted.
Beaming up.
Notify transporter room.
Blake: Sort of around
the time of "Star Trek,"
we had landed on the moon,
We felt like we were being
very ambitious as explorers.
And the idea of being able
to get someplace fast
is something that
we're all obsessed with.
As a viewer, you hear
all of these science words.
It seems like a thing
that might be possible.
It uses trionic initiators
in the warp core.
Keith:
So who am I, as a 10-year-old
watching this show,
not to think, "Yeah, maybe
they've got it figured out."
Part of the promise
of "Star Trek"
is believing that we could
get there someday.
But teleportation
is one of those things that,
it's so far off as a technology
to be able to achieve,
and those things are possible
only in science fiction.
Marques:
So, one of the most important
aspects of a teleporter
is it has to completely
disassemble and reassemble you
in the exact right place
every single time.
But what would it take
on a physics level
to build a machine
with that type of accuracy?
To help me understand
what's possible,
I'm meeting up with Kevin
from Vsauce2,
who's known for breaking down
some of the world's
biggest complexities.
Kevin, welcome
to "Retro Tech."
Thanks for having me.
I love your place.
What should we know
about teleporters?
What is actually possible
right now?
Well, we're talking
about teleporting, like,
really, really,
really small things,
like a photon.
That's possible
with quantum entanglement,
- which is crazy.
- Fair.
Yeah, I imagine
a lot of what we're
seeing in the movies
is either an exaggeration
of the little bit
that's possible
or just completely impossible.
We can't exactly visualize
what it would look like
if you were dematerialized
down into atoms,
so let's just pretend
that you turned into light.
- Marques: All right.
- It's called the double
slit experiment.
It gets complicated.
Try to stay with me here.
Imagine our teleporter machine
dematerializes you
into these light photons,
and these two slits represent
the atmosphere pathways
your beamed body
will travel through
on your way
to your destination.
I am ready to see this.
Let's energize.
- Huh. That is weird.
- ( Kevin laughs )
Somehow it turns into
a horizontal string of beads.
This is called
an interference pattern.
First of all, if you were
to get into a teleporter,
we don't want you to be
that series of beads.
It's not gonna be
a great result for you.
If you were a light beam
transported,
you might end up
in a scattered mess,
which would be bad.
But atoms act
differently than light,
so in theory your atoms
will be less scattered
going through those pathways
and easier
to put back together.
But when scientists did
the same experiment with atoms,
the stuff you
and I are made of,
they found atoms
weirdly behaved the same way.
They weren't sure
why this was happening,
so scientists tried
to observe the atoms.
But when they pointed
a detector to track the atoms,
they changed
their coordinates,
meaning atoms
can act like both waves
and particles when in motion.
To this day, scientists have
still no clue why,
but just observing
your atoms in motion
can change their destination,
which would be
really bad for you,
the person teleporting.
It's like when
you're playing "Mario Bros"
and you look at the Boo
and it stops,
and then you turn around
and it chases you.
The observation of it
definitely changes behavior.
- Wow, that--
- Yeah.
That does hurt
my brain a little bit.
So maybe we're still
very far away
from actually being
able to teleport,
but what if we could achieve
almost the same experience
without even
leaving our homes?
Narrator:
By strapping on 3D
visual display goggles,
one can be immersed
into new worlds.
The experience
of virtual reality
is similar to teleportation
in that your body,
your consciousness,
your awareness
was somewhere else,
+and instantaneously
you are in a completely
different environment.
Marques:
All right, let's talk about
the history of VR.
How did this whole
VR thing start?
You get into the '80s and '90s
and you get the Eye Phone.
No, not that iPhone.
This was the "eye,"
so, E-Y-E Phone.
You had an individual
named Jaron Lanier
who wanted to create
a new type of instrument.
These are the special glasses
called the Eye Phones.
When you put them on,
you're seeing inside
an imaginary world
instead of inside
the physical world.
Greg:
It was a giant headset.
A huge computer had to run it.
It cost a ton of money.
But what you got
was a virtual world
that responded to your touch
and what you saw.
Blake:
It was really the Eye Phone
that helped introduce
virtual reality as a product
that you might have in
your lifetime to the masses.
Throughout the '90s,
video games became more
and more realistic,
so that became
a great first frontier
for virtual reality to exist.
In my mall, they had these
VR arcade experiences,
like "Dactyl Nightmare."
Reporter:
Truly cutting-edge technology,
but to my eyes,
these units still have
a way to go.
- But there was a problem.
- It was making people sick.
Headaches, nausea, sweats.
- ( woman laughing )
- Oh, my God!
- I can see seagulls.
- Okay, it's broken.
Blake: All types of things
that are connected
to motion sickness.
What early VR did have though,
was that it looked futuristic.
It looked super high tech.
None of them
actually did much,
but they looked cool
when your friends came over.
Marques:
So, despite the technology
being far from perfect,
virtual reality headsets
promised to immediately
transport us
to another world.
So, today I'm joined
by Jake from Game Ranks
and we're gonna test out
some of the retro VR
and maybe get a little dizzy
in the process.
This is Dope Or Nope.
- First of all,
Jake, welcome back.
- Hey, thanks for having me.
Season two.
Love when we have people back.
We got this first thing
coming to us from the year 1993.
I'm ready to
get jacked in, so...
For sure.
Let's plug ourselves in.
Stuntmaster Virtual Reality.
I already feel,
uh, young, because what
does that phrase mean?
The first phrase
in the marketing copy.
"Race the car. Fly the jet.
Wear that shirt.
Confront. Engage. Fire."
- Wait a second, okay.
- Yeah, this is a lot.
Race the car?
I would like to.
- Cool.
- Sounds exciting.
Fly the jet?
Again, probably wouldn't be
able to do that in real life.
Wear the shirt?
That seems like a big step down.
- Maybe that's a metaphor?
"Wear that shirt."
- Wow, okay.
- All right.
- Whatever it is, we need
to be in a mainframe.
Yeah, let's-- let's see it.
Let's get the actual
Stuntmaster headset going.
"Attach the clip
to the shoulder area
of the shirt."
- Wear that shirt!
That's what it means.
- Oh.
All right,
I'm just gonna put it on.
You went for it.
Are you ready?
- I am ready.
- Welcome to the real world.
Oh, I heard something.
Super Mario World.
Is it actually 3-D
or is it just a screen
in your face?
It's not 3-D at all.
It's honestly just a worse
version of playing on a TV.
This is like the worst
Gameboy in my face.
- Oh, my face hurts so bad.
- Oh, man.
That might be the heaviest
VR headset I've ever worn.
Everything about it is pain.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
- Kevin: A big nope.
- Yeah.
- Yes!
- Oh, wow.
- SegaScope 3-D System.
- Look at the dad.
He's like, "Yeah, son.
Do that violence. Good work."
Marques: You can't
see the 3D part, Dad.
Why are you cheering?
Here is the phaser.
Does it make a cool click
like the Nintendo gun?
No-- ooh.
- Not satisfying at all.
- Huh.
- Now, the console itself.
- The console itself.
Look at that unit.
It is '80s as hell.
It looks like a car stereo.
Oh, and you plug this
into your TV.
This is very big.
Why do you have this?
It's retro tech.
You gotta have a TV.
Start the game
with the gun maybe.
Magic. Oh, wow.
Do they feel like
they're flying towards you?
Marques: It's not
a very impressive depth.
'Cause they look like it here,
just in a flickering,
crappy way.
- You did it. Good job.
- I saved the city.
Jake: That's actually
kind of impressive,
if not for the rampant
flickering that I know
is making me sick.
Low-key,
a little bit overpromising?
Jake: I think it would
get old pretty fast.
I think it's
too much hassle,
too much setup.
SegaScope 3-D, that's a nope.
Jake:
That's a big nope.
This guy.
Virtual Reality World
V.R. Ninja.
It's a VR headset,
and you are fighting
another ninja
based on your own moves.
Do you want to check out
what kind of sensor
they have in here?
Yeah, a little mot--
that's a big sensor.
- ( rattles )
- You know what
that's telling me?
That's telling me
it's a capacitive
closed-circuit type
motion sensor.
It's just a little
metal ball inside
hitting the metal
outside of the thing.
And if it touches, you moved,
It touches the other side,
you moved.
Pretty simple.
It's not an accelerometer.
- You're so smart.
- I was hoping for
an accelerometer.
So, to me, this is the closest
to modern-day VR so far.
I need your guidance.
Do you know how to fight?
Uh, barely.
Like, I was a yellow belt
in Tae Kwon Do.
Nice. All right, cool.
- There you go.
- I feel cool now.
- That fits surprisingly well.
- Do you mind?
I got to look for the--
yeah, power.
All right. I see-- it just
looks like a calculator screen.
- Does it--
- Not a good sign.
Also, do you hear?
It's pushing down on my nose
and I'm talking like Squidward.
Dude, it looks like about
30 pounds on your face.
There's a time counting down
and there's ninjas. Okay.
That sounds
like it's working.
So, unfortunately,
it relies on sound.
That's the only way
I can know if I get a hit.
- Oh, sorry.
Where are you?
- I'm good. We're good.
Nothing's happening
when I punch the men.
I think I hate it.
Oh, my God.
- Good luck putting that on.
- Let's get in the game.
Oh, my God, that is sharp.
It's stabbing me in the face.
I don't see anything right now.
You're about to see...
everything.
- Oh!
- Good stance.
You're getting hit.
Do it.
- Oh! Oh!
- That's a hit.
Yeah, that's a hit.
There-- wow!
All right, wow, okay.
- ( laughs )
- I lost.
VR-wise, this is
the worst VR version.
It absolutely does not react
to the orientation
of your head or anything.
- Nothing.
- It is the best
looking one, though.
- It is, yeah.
- Verdict?
It wasn't very good
and it stabbed me in the face.
- Yeah.
- So, I still have
to give it a nope.
- That is a nope.
- For the first time,
we've given all nopes,
and yet I still think
we see, like, they're on
to something happening.
Yeah, it just is a disaster.
Marques:
So, clearly early VR gaming
was not very good.
The technology simply
wasn't advanced enough yet,
and most at this point had
given up on the VR industry.
The year is 2012,
not that long ago.
But it was long ago enough
that people thought
virtual reality was a joke,
it was a punch line.
We all thought it was done.
It made you nauseous.
But there were a few people
that still loved VR,
and one of them was a teenager
named Palmer Lucky.
Virtual reality,
people have been wanting it
for a really long time.
We finally have the technology
to make it happen.
It used gyroscopes,
accelerometers, you know,
sensors that we know very well
from the Eye Phone,
and the latency was super low.
Blake: The sensors,
they're able to so quickly
calculate in real time
what should be there
when you look that way,
and that's what really
tricked your brain
into thinking
that you're somewhere else.
All of a sudden,
we thought for a second,
"Hey, this might be
a thing again
because of head tracking."
And it was this idea
that just by putting on
this pair of glasses,
these goggles,
you could be anywhere.
Really bringing it back
to teleportation.
A lot of times with technology,
we're not even conceiving
of something that's
just about to arrive.
The day before
the iPhone was announced,
we didn't even conceive
that a phone was able
to do those things.
So who knows?
Maybe someone is working
on teleportation right now
and we're gonna have
the ability to teleport.
Marques: So, back to
the original question.
Is teleportation technology
closer than we think?
Well, to find out, I'm gonna
speak with astrophysicist
and all-around great guy
Dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson,
and hopefully he can
shed some light on this
and tell us if we're any closer
to actually beaming up.
Neil deGrasse Tyson,
thank you for joining me.
Would it be, do you think,
ever physically possible
to build this idea
we've imagined
of the teleportation machine?
I think central
to the teleportation machine
is the memory
of how all of your molecules
are configured.
It's an information
processing challenge.
I can turn you into energy
and then move that energy
to the other place
and then convert that energy
back into particles.
But I have to remember,
I need the instruction set
to reassemble you.
Because once
it becomes energy,
you've lost all
of that information.
So, have we ever converted
anything to energy?
Yeah, we do that in particle
accelerators all the time.
Like, you can
reconstruct the same shape
in a different place,
but remembering where each
molecule is inside that shape?
So, let's go to a "Star Trek"
style teleportation.
So, it disassembles
your molecules,
turns you into
a beam of energy,
reassembles it
on the other side.
All right,
so is that still you?
I have to say no.
It is a copy of you.
And basically you just
divided yourself into two--
basically cloning.
Now, how do we turn
that into you?
What we'd need to do is
not simply copy the molecules,
you have to copy
the neurosynaptic memories
that you carry
in your brain's molecules.
All right, so, boom!
It disappears here,
shows up over there.
It is there instantly,
so that all your particles
will disappear
simultaneously
and then show up
in another place.
I don't know how
to teleport memories
that exist in the static
molecules of your brain.
If you could do that,
then I'm convinced
we are moving you
from one location to another.
Do you think if virtual reality
can get good enough
that maybe that's enough
to satisfy that part
of our curiosity
where we want to transport
just to see cool things?
We'll just sort of put
the headset on and be there.
Yes, we've taken baby steps
in that direction.
But if you could smell the air
and feel the breeze
and watch the birds
fly over it,
maybe that's sufficient.
You don't know
whether you are looking
at an image or reality.
At that point,
I don't think it matters
whether you actually go
to the Grand Canyon.
And then you can just change
where your location is.
But does it matter
that it's real?
That's a different question.
The knowledge that it's real
seems to matter to us.
You know, what is real?
I sound like Morpheus.
( Neil imitating Morpheus )
What is real?
How do you define real?
If your brain is everything,
then traveling doesn't matter.
We'll just inject it in you.
That could come.
Well, that's really deep.
Thank you again.
- I love your shirt.
- Oh, thank you.
Yeah, actually it's a vest.
I've got about a half dozen.
Ah, that's beautiful.
All right,
so after all that,
it can feel easy
to get pretty down
on ever seeing,
ever witnessing
real life teleportation,
which I get.
But I love this switch
that we flipped,
where instead
of teleporting ourselves
from point A to point B,
the tech that turns out
makes a lot more sense
is bringing B to A instantly.
It's powerful.
And that is now the new future
that I'm really
looking forward to.
Thanks for watching.
Catch you guys
on the next one.
Peace.